a days little boy is pulled from rubble
like so many of the young here he
doesn't make a sound he doesn't cry and
he doesn't shout he just accepts what's
happening as he's left in the back of an
ambulance the size of the chair he's put
on just underlines how very small and
young music and he seems to be on his
own but his composure is startling as he
feels blood running down his cheeks and
deals with it he's become the face of
Aleppo this is what happens when a siege
is broken in Syria regime rocket strikes
on an area cracked with children Basha
what is this child
ever done he's saying our cameraman
arrives minutes after the attack two
scenes a fear and desperation all
shockingly common here
[Applause]
aleppo civilians call it Bashar's
revenge a barrage of bombings as
punishment for supporting the opposition
they're hitting children this man says
everyone here is a civilian and small
children small children he is only one
year old and this is some sort of
progress the strikes from the Syrian
government troops the relentless attacks
on children and families are an attempt
to wrestle back control of Aleppo after
opposition groups finally broke the
regime stranglehold and these are rebel
groups not including Isis different
fighting units whose unity appears to
have had a striking and immediate impact
on the battlefield in his first British
television interview a senior figure
within the most powerful rebel group
told us it's that collaboration which
has proved a game-changer we hope that
this decision to form JFS will help
unify the forces that will bring an end
to all of this suffering and pain and if
you look at our success of breaking the
siege in Aleppo anyone can see how unity
is definitely the major game-changer in
Syria the front for the liberation of
Syria or JFS gave us these pictures they
say it shows their fighters at the heart
of the battle to break the Aleppo siege
thousands of soldiers the most
experienced military commanders all
logistic efforts came together in order
to foil the attempts of these Four
Horsemen of the Syrian Apocalypse the
Assad regime Russia Iran and the
militias of Hezbollah our role was
integral in all fields especially the
planning and execution of of military
operations it's a dramatic turnaround
for the rebel forces and many are
putting these battlefield successes down
to the JFS decision to change its name
from jabot al-nusra and significantly
cut its links
al Qaeda is this a permanent split from
al Qaeda or just a very timely one it's
certainly not something temporary this
is a necessary step forward in order to
achieve the very much needed unification
of ranks in Syria and one of the core
reasons as a paternal initially was
disbanded and we created then JFS was to
remove any potential obstacles that may
impede the success of a merger like
unnecessary affiliations the rebel
groups have been mostly welcomed by
Aleppo's weary civilians but the JFS
success will concern some Western
governments primarily the Americans who
still see the group as terrorists and
who will fear their agenda if Western
governments are expecting us to come out
and say that we want a Western liberal
democracy secular democracy they have to
understand it as a Muslim society our
core beliefs and values define all
spheres of our life they shaped our
identity they set a system of governance
that will remove oppression and
establish a system that will see justice
for everyone as for our objectives and
ideology like you asked Alex we have
never been secretive about them and that
will send a shudder down the spines of
Western politicians whose inaction in
the face of these attacks not just in
Aleppo but a host of other towns
besieged by Syrian government forces
means the civilians view the rebel
groups as their only slim hope Alex
Crawford Sky News
you